dans l'île de vancouver un splendide
manoir a suscité beaucoup d'intérêt en
2020 car un couple célèbre il ya élu
domicile pendant quelques mois le prince
héritier
et leur fille sotchi
mais qui donc était le mystérieux
propriétaire de la demeure temporaire du
couple princier
selon une voisine le nom du milliardaire
russe yuri milner circulent depuis des
années
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yuri milner a fait fortune à silicon
valley il a été un important actionnaire
de facebook et de twitter dans le passé
il a fondé une organisation qui
récompense des scientifiques lors de
galas animés par de grandes vedettes
cette opulente résidence de 100 millions
de dollars américains en californie lui
appartient on dit qu'il possède aussi
semer ghayatt de plus de 100 mètres
landreau meda ce qu'il a publiquement
nié
yuri milner n'est pas un des oligarques
proche de poutine mais une enquête du
new york times et du consortium
international des journalistes d'
enquête a révélé en 2010 est qu'une
partie des fonds qu'il a investi dans
facebook provenaient de gazprom une
société d'état russe ils ont été versés
par l'entremise d'amis chers usmanov un
oligarque maintenant sanctionné mais en
eux a aussi reçu des millions de dollars
du kremlin pour investir dans tout et e
par l'entremise de vtb une banque russe
[Musique]
soit
mais il nous affirme n'avoir reçu aucun
fonds provenant de la russie depuis 2011
lorsque nous l'avons contacté son
assistante nous a affirmé que ni mineur
ni sa famille ni des sociétés qui lui
sont liées ne possède le fameux manoir
dans l'île de vancouver
au registre foncier impossible de
trouver des informations sur l'identité
du véritable propriétaire mais nous
avons trouvé une piste dans les pandora
paper cette fuite de documents
confidentiels provenant des paradis
fiscaux le manoir est détenu par une
société écran incorporé aux îles vierges
britanniques
j e mc management limited qui appartient
à son tour à une société des bahamas
elle-même administré par une fiducie
cette fiducie nommé andromeda s'appelait
auparavant la fiducie du riz mis en
oeuvre selon l'un des documents
confidentiels yuri milner exercer un
contrôle sur une série de sociétés dont
j emc management la société liée au
manoir nous avons montré les documents à
patrice poidevin un enquêteur de la grc
à la retraite on prend pour acquis que
les documents sont vérité ce que ça
démontre ce que monsieur mire ne a un
intérêt direct sur la propriété lorsque
nous avons présenté les résultats de
notre enquête à yuri milner il a admis
que sa fiducie a bel et bien acquis le
manoir de l'île de vancouver en 2013
cependant il affirme qu'il ne contrôle
et ne bénéficient plus de cette fiducie
y compris le manoir au canada depuis
2014 que ce sont plutôt des fondations
caritatives qui en sont les
bénéficiaires
dans sa réponse milner admet aussi
qu'une fiducie qui la constituent et à
acheter les y attend andromeda mais il
affirme que ni lui ni sa famille ne sont
bénéficiaires ou affiliés aux actifs de
cette fiducie c'est facile de mettre un
nom sur un morceau de papier mais
ultimement qui or qui a eu les fonds
pour acheter ses textes cette propriété
et qui contrôle la vente et le revenu de
cette propriété s'il ya six ans
après l'éclatement du conflit en ukraine
le gouvernement trudeau a annoncé qu'il
allait accélérer la mise sur pied d'un
registre des véritables propriétaires et
société incorporée au fédéral je pense
que vraiment c'est inacceptable
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas les données
fiables
en ce qui concerne
les propriétés au canada
le canada perdra-t-il sa réputation de
refuge pour les investisseurs qui
souhaitent rester dans l'ombre jusqu'à
présent ottawa et la plupart des
provinces ont fait bien pu pour
s'attaquer à ce problème mais le vent
semble tourner en faveur d'une plus
grande transparence